we all have secrets some we share and
some we keep to ourselves from trips
throughout to Disney Vista secrets they
might not even know themselves keep
watching for these five Disney
Princesses and their family secrets
let's get started if there's one thing
we can count on Disney for it it's a
happily ever after with the Apple some
faith trust and pixie dust things need
to always turn out okay for our favorite
princesses and who needs a prince when
you've got your very own your fairy
godmother oh that's right rumor has it
that every Disney character has a fairy
godmother making sure they don't get
into too much trouble I mean there's a
reason we call them fairy tales it's no
secret that fairies have helped save the
day and many of Disney's earlier films
from the Blue Fairy and Pinocchio to the
three fairies and Sleeping Beauty and
even the most popular fairy godmother
who makes all of Cinderella's dreams
come true the fairies have left the
spotlight to take care of their very own
Kingdom Pixie Hollow that's right we've
been introduced to many of these fairies
and Disney's fairies franchise take a
look at these uncanny resemblances
[Music]
boo is a little girl who travels through
doors only to find herself in the world
of monsters Inc this is where she runs
into her favorite monsters Mike and
Sulley Mike and Sulley spend their time
trying to get boo back home safely that
is at the end of the film we see that
saying goodbye to boo wasn't easy
especially not for her friend Sulley he
would eventually have to leave her
sparking her interest in transporting
doors boo would then make it her life's
mission to get back to her friend Sulley
does this remind you of anyone the witch
from brave who transports through doors
perhaps with all the evidence to support
it this is more than just a wild guess
whose real name according to this
drawing is Mary the little girl who
voices boo in the movie is Mary Gibbs
now both her first and last name have
Scottish origins dun broch where the
movie brave was set is a mystical
Scottish Kingdom if that isn't enough
the witches workshop definitely gives us
enough evidence to support this theory
check out this large carving of Sulley
in one of her winning boards remember
when she says she's off to the Wickerman
festival
well the Wickerman festival doesn't
first take place until the year 2001
that's the same year the Monsters Inc
movie was released not to mention her
clear obsession with bears one of the
last things boo associates with Sulley
or maybe even mermaids are one of the
most beautiful mystical creatures we are
first introduced to they first make an
appearance in Disney's classic animated
film Peter Pan Peter Pan was released in
1953 that's about 36 years before the
release of the iconic Little Mermaid
animation now would you believe me if I
told you that these two movies were
linked together by a mermaid with long
beautiful red hair green eyes an aqua
tail and a beautiful singing voice some
of you might think I'm talking about
Ariel but this mermaid was spotted in
Neverland long before Ariel was born her
name is Athena Athena first makes an
appearance in the beginning of the
Little Mermaid Ariel's beginning we only
get a short scene of the character
before she is hit by a pirate ship
leaving the storyline completely there
is enmity between Athena and the mermaid
in Peter Pan
is hard to argue against especially
considering the two different time
period
which they were drawing we then see
Athena again in Peter Pan to return to
Neverland except this time she's a lot
older now it's no secret that people
don't age or change in Neverland so
where was it Thea and the time between
these two movies living her best life in
Atlantic oh of course Disney Princesses
have been great role models for many of
us growing up they teach us the
importance of things like kindness
courage being true to ourselves and even
following our own destiny this couldn't
be more true than in Disney's frozen and
all-time Disney favorite frozen takes us
through the lives of Anna and Elsa who
possessed special abilities that's right
you heard correctly
both of these princesses have special
abilities that make them unique as we
see throughout the movie Elsa is totally
able to control the elements of ice and
snow
Anna and the other hands has been
showing signs of super strength and even
an affinity for fire Anna and Elsa's
story can be compared to the story of
two other sisters Kira and Hestia
according to Greek mythology here had
powers so strong she could control
everything in existence including the
seasons in Lou Evan Hesse on the other
hand was known for her love generosity
and kindness what makes this story even
more convincing is the badges we see on
Anna and Elsa's father he has seen
dressed in a royal suit adorned in
badges now one of these badges shows a
clear symbol for fire throughout the
years Disney has given us many mystical
and magical movies from up in the
heavens with the Greek gods of Mount
Olympus - under the seat and the mermaid
full kingdom of Atlantica and everything
in between what if I was to tell you
that all these worlds you could sit in
one unified Disney verse if we lay them
out according to the time period their
sudden it's not that hard to believe
for starters in the Little Mermaid we
see that Ariel's father is King Triton
King Triton is the son of Poseidon now
Hercules his father is none other than
Zeus Poseidon's brother this would make
the two redheads Ariel and Hercules
cousins could this theory hold up
against the fact it definitely could if
we considered that all Disney characters
live in the same magical world now this
would make total sense and could explain
why we see scar and Hercules Poseidon
and Princess on the Frog and even
Pinocchio entangled
make sure to let me know in the comments
section below all the times you
different Disney worlds come together
that is the end of our video thank you
for watching and see you next time on
the things
[Music]